when I was in Boston had a great show
Wilbur then I'm with my boy Moloch it
was my feature I'm gonna see [ __ ]
hilarious
what is this last weekend this is this
is this Friday this past New Year's Eve
confusing so so my boy Brian Cooley who
has a jujitsu school in in Nashville
he's six six and he was a ranger before
this he's a big guy who's a competitive
he competes but he's just a giant Viking
man so I'm with I'm with I'm with Brian
cool he he flew up there yeah he flew up
there with his wife Natalie awesome yeah
good friends look real whiskey guy
okay real [ __ ] whiskey guy next time
you'll be a judge with that so um so I
got Brian there I got Moloch who came
out of who has been boxing since he was
seven came out of Floyd Mayweather's
camp does a lot you know and then I got
Lex Friedman who does Rogan he's the guy
who does the deals with the robotics and
the Tesla's for you on Musk
he's the MIT professor yeah it's black
belt in judo and jujitsu okay and then
my boy Rob Bradley who's a black belt in
jujitsu as well so I'm rolling kind of
deep with some big fellas Rob's big you
know six I think I like him eat a lot of
meat it's not like the nerdy version of
it I'm the nerdy I'm the nerdy version I
heard event correct yeah now my boy
mouse got his beautiful Ethiopian girl
okay yeah chocolate yes my other boy
Justin's got his Eritrean girl night
Eritrea is the country that's above
Ethiopia there but beautiful women in
that part of the world no she's not
they're both black so Hank you the mo
thank you but as is Maalik and much more
just inducted so so now now we're
dancing a me and Malik Malik 27 we're
having a dance-off
we're right at the bar at this club
right near the W but being silly kidding
I wish you weren't dancing but everybody
was I'm the old guy having a dance of a
mug joking around fun but we're having a
[ __ ] silly time just did a show I'm
just having a good time be an idiot
now if this is going to you fighting
gets better as I would fight you if I
sell you dancin you should yeah now I'm
noticing that this guy these these men
who I reckon you know how I can pick out
nationalities right away oh yeah and
that's I've ever seen them yep there are
there four African gentlemen and I
happen to clock
and I go those guys are clearly from
Ethiopia and they're staring you down
well there now remember my boys with an
Ethiopian gal oh I'm one of them Strunk
and he starts kind of walking up to the
girls that were with and they're getting
kind of one guys getting kind of grabby
now hold on yeah I'll just try and paint
this now you know hey now I know you
behold on these Ethiopian men when I
think Ethiopians yeah because we're
where I come from yes bring up Ethiopian
with a small and skinny
that's right Brenda okay that's right
Brendon it's five seven seven to a man
matters I'm Alice they're beautiful
people remember these people gorgeous
but fives are small they're typically
not giant they're not giant no they tend
to be slight there's that there you go
there they're small good knocking now
hitting them lets them tread lightly
here that the one are they also the same
or it may be one get confused with
Somalia pirates where I'm the captain
now okay so that would be Somalia which
is next to Ethiopia very modern culture
okay one is Muslim the other Coptic
Christian I'm saying do they look
similar
yes no East African it's it's very very
diverse racially actually aggression
like not so much East Africa's got
really different looking people right
back those stories sorry for those side
try I'm just I'm glad but but if you
look at that like small or very small or
a field yes very fine features and small
there you go that's a classic example
you think very good-looking people known
for their look yes okay now these guys
because they've been Americanized a
little heavy and not so good-looking and
kind of shitty in general now here's why
now I'm rolling with skinny fat building
feel be yeah and I'm rolling with
I'm rolling with some American black
guys who aren't hearing a peep now and
yeah we're talking about the other side
of Africa by the way probably
ancestrally West African which is
different thing and now I got giant
Viking white guy I got I got Russian guy
and ladies American I got big Irish guy
my buddies merican these are Americans
yeah you understand all Alexa's Russia
now so so now but you know you know
Albright rise insecure and get super hot
headed by now situation just lost lost
what in the less skilled correct right I
am glad you said it
who's the first gotta fight mostly
skillful you Brian the Chihuahua most
into our most insecure the old scalawag
Chihuahua Ricky by the way my name is
rink so thank you very much sorry man
right I mean everywhere I go thanks I'm
getting screamed out in the whole foods
for God's sake in [ __ ] Utah get to
Park City right like I walk in rags dude
oh my god Jesus Christ so there it is
and I'm walking I hear about the counter
raves that's my name so rinse the
Chihuahua starts to bark so I I and I
yeah I like words I like somebody knows
how to use word yeah so this guy is now
all of a sudden music stops and this guy
looks right at my bookmark and goes hey
that's our sister man that's our sister
you shouldn't be with our sister oh and
I go what and he goes man shut up you
don't know if the pho I go I go the [ __ ]
you talk now I'm numb and now there get
their posturing now Malik Malik
literally you could be as long as he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like he's
literally he's already diffused three
fights he could give a [ __ ] he's so such
a goofball he's not even noticing the
areas there is hilarious oh look at him
lifting weights oh I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] him up for that is that he's
so high the way one of us a silly goose
all lives only to be a silly good okay
so now he's not even he's not giving him
anything and I'm like what the [ __ ] oh
that's this is so he has no [ __ ] these
things right Brian Brian this is how
Brian could diffuse to tell me you
looked everywhere I'm the captain now I
didn't say [ __ ] Brian just got what I
would have said coolly goes like this
cool he goes hey bro you know jaws and
the guy goes y-yes jaws in the movie you
know John have accents
yeah they not rude a head to accents but
they spoke very very games
you got goes yeah and he goes you're the
girl enjoy swimming in the water just
having a swim I've got no idea
there's a shark gonna pull him under I'm
the clown the shark I'm gonna pull you
under it was the greatest [ __ ] thing
and he's so big and and he's just like
sitting there looking up I'm the
shakopee you're the girl in charge swim
think I gave him the thumbs up in his
bucket
both took a look and they're like ah
this is a bath it should be a very bad
it was so [ __ ] great from the shore
it was so great it was great he was he's
just he's so big and intimidating
military guys it's like oh god you know
you know what's crazy I love that you
know what's crazy to me is when people
that like that happens and they don't
read the situation and they keep going
it's like oh are you [ __ ] as they're
drunk or they actually think we're just
it's like happening you've never had
anybody do that to you though right no
not really I mean but there are people
myself I'll hang out well that you know
what I did I don't think it came out of
like 'man you say it all I'm especially
in Boston dude New Year's what are you
doing so how about corrector you doing
what am I doing wrong I said it
now listen um we came up on the street
it's 1:00 in the morning it's now what I
say to her gym ball I said all oh my god
okay it's the bear base getting a hotel
now nothing that happens right now
nothing good happens on the street
nothing
III heard everybody like like a [ __ ]
collie
another thing Justin and it happens and
then I came back out that's for
Ethiopian guys were there oh and hey hey
you went on the captain they surrounded
me and then just around it hey guys fat
belly cuz they're not eating hey you
guys out first swim yeah you guys out
for a swim
how's the water is it choppy I slew them
I slew all of them us my friends the
shark yeah and I'm the batter ho down
the old squid honey all squeal I must
suck you boys are I do around the squid
I squeezed I choke them I tend to suck
it you know I don't on the squid calm
you guys down right quick with my mouth
the old squid old bring alright for
Circle their girls nothing dude was your
crowd a little rowdy on Year's Eve what
did you do three two one I did you did
word they were so great and they've some
of them were older it was really wild I
was like this year crowds definitely
older had a meet-and-greet didn't know
there 100 people waiting I was at home
and in the [ __ ] squid but it was
great now we did it we did oh do I knew
so I did two shows at the ice house ice
won't stay local you know so I did two
shows there yeah and for show great
fantastic second show yeah the rowdy
mess little rally ice Whitney I go
because I had Fahim on the first show
than I had Brian since you know Brian
Simpson he got passed at the store he's
a monster black dude at the store
monster alert so I had a son Brian
Simpson Derek and love see myself there
is so funny
such a bright I don't know killer yeah
[ __ ] killer so I had a pocket yeah so
I had him on the The Late Show Early
Show at Fahim but I was gonna have
Whitney come by to and Whitney goes I
don't do New Year's Eve well she was too
rowdy yeah I'm like no only woody Tom
out first time like it was she time less
easy second show it's just that there's
a lot of booze going around well there
are a lot of fights that broke out in
Boston
I'm sure that's boss in the hotel I'm
there next Saturday yeah in the W so but
there's alcohol there and then you know
when they're doing the count -
everyone's waiting for it so they're
distracted they're dropping the check it
was just like it's almost like I was
doing stand-up at a restaurant because
there's like talking cuz they're ready
to go it was just different yep it's
just different
yeah I'm never comfortable in crowds
especially on times like New Year's Eve
know I've been just have anxiety people
die of all the time in any any crowds I
have anxiety if I'm same way I'm not
none of my shows I don't but if we go
out after like so a restaurant or
somewhere or like I'm at the mall with
my family it's all like it's so out of
character for me to go to a club so I
that's very strange
yeah I never but it was writing the
other end it was actually part of the
hotel yeah I was like we're here when I
when I was in Philly we you know we had
on the show late when we walk in there
guy goes ah the guy we get back in not
over
hi Brandon or Brennan I don't know but
not around here yeah - goober get back
to your side yep My Damn gonna watch out
for you he'll watch out for you
yeah he was great yep great man didn't
you tell me you were walking in Norton
Arlen's nollans and the cops were like
you guys don't go down that way you're
walking the wrong way
oh yeah yeah we're walking he just
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your UFC stuff
they have something called pissed all us
Oh stall us if you go one block left of
yeah Marty girl Street where the [ __ ]
about my dad 78 year old friend one of
his oldest friends I start to tell a
story about the big guy I got I'm wrong
deep I got one guy was like 6 6 and he
goes he in middle of my story in front
of both our families extended families
he goes what is this about you big guys
with you you're always talking about
muscle guys and yeah he goes you're gay
thank you yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]